The joe rogan experience.
You're not a Boston comic?
No,
not at all.
I grew up in Wooster in Wooster,
Massachusetts as I was
old enough to leave.
You are a Boston comic.
Whether you like it or not,
there's a reason why there's
so many fucking funny guys
from that shitty part of
the country and it's not shitty.
Which shit?
His shitty.
Yeah,
the weather's Shitty.
The girl,
I think everything about,
well,
not everything,
obviously hyperbole,
but I did not know.
The girls were nice till I moved to La.
I didn't know they were
capable of being nice.
I fucking dumb as shit.
We're fucking hillbillies,
man.
Eddie Bravo's any problem?
Probably just girl.
I met this girl in Boston and she,
it was just a fucking Hail Mary
sacrifice two in the morning,
move way back in the day,
many,
many decades ago,
and anyway.
She goes,
wow.
While he's like making out with her,
it pulls his dick out,
whatever.
He goes,
she goes,
can it tell you friends
about girls in Boston?
That's,
that's what I remember growing up.
I remember the only time I ever got
to fuck with the girls were so sloppy,
drunk and belligerent that it was like
we had to argue before we get to fuck.
And then when we did it,
when it was over,
I was like,
oh,
I got to go home and get
me the fuck away from this.
You better fucking Kwame Kwame.
There's still like that.
It's,
it's a cold weather.
Is it the fucking savages that lived there
that came over on boats from Ireland?
One of my first real girlfriends,
when I say 16,
17,
uh,
I kept in touch with her,
you know,
remotely here and again.
And I remember I had to be in my
thirties gone back and I call in.
Yeah,
we'll have a drink and I,
hey,
you look really good.
And she goes,
yeah.
She goes,
yeah,
well maybe if you hadn't have fucked
Sherry Munson was still beating again.
They're
17 years old.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
oh,
that's so fucking funny.
But they do,
they hold on to that shit forever.
That's a fucking get
out of jail free card.
It's one of those few pat myself on the
back times in my is is is just comparing
myself to most of the people we grew up
with and knowing that one night in my
life would be something
they would remember.
That would be like the
fucking biggest shit.
I don't remember doing.
I've done television shows
that I don't remember.
Wait,
oh,
you were on my show and I'm like,
Eh.
Sounds familiar.
If they were on the news
once in the background,
they'd have a still photo
of it somewhere in there.
Fucking grubby.
I can Foxboro Framingham fucking
route nine route nine the auto mall.
Oh,
when I was 21 years old,
you could have easily talked me into
doing some fucking colony course.
Right.
I would have saved up my money.
Took an acting course I got was completely
ripped off when I was 18 I had a bad
acting teacher who was going to
earn while you learn program,
are they going to get you
gigs while they fucking,
you paid them to go weekly,
but we'll,
we'll get you working.
Get Ya to casting agents.
They do that with models too,
right?
How is a classic,
took the train to la.
As soon as I was 18 went
400 bucks in my pocket.
I get off the train at union station
and I'm going to be an actor.
Why?
It didn't work out.
When I was in Boston,
every girl had a modeling photo.
Remember when girls,
what you used to go to
modeling Casablanca?
Yeah,
and they would take a photo of the girl
or standing like this and like her hair
blowing in the wind and the poses.
They would spend all this money.
It was basically a huge scam where they
would just get these girls to spend a
fuckload of money on getting their photos
taken and then they get their photos
taken with this guy's logo at the bottom
of it and they would send it out and
nothing would ever happen.
But it was like these curls
like cabin doing some modeling.
I recently got some new shots,
did some modeling.
Every fucking God damn was a models.
Crazy bitches.
You weren't even that good.
Look at it.
Tell your friends
tell you if
I can't even early in the night drunk,
she was drunk and I was
just trying to avoid her.
I was trying to avoid her.
I was just trying to avoid
her and she goes to me,
you think you're off?
DFAC
younger my face with this fucking
thing in the fingers moving.
He thinks we have facts like those
girls get sloppy drunk every weekend.
Those are the trends.
They know what the fuck they're
doing is fucking just milky.
All believed in and
shaved pussies wiring,
cigarette breath and
fucking dirty ass holes.
It's dilute vein titties,
black fucking shearing socks and make
your feet sweat and it's smelling shit
tube top belly hair,
blue eyes shadow thrown up in the Torah.
Tell leave,
don't
leave
you fucking as,
oh
my God.
Can you imagine having a,
if I ran into half the chicks I boned
as a teenager now cause they were pigs
then.
Oh I see him now at our age.
Oh.
I went and found my,
my original high school girlfriend on
Facebook and I opened up her thing and
said,
send her a message and I went like that
with my fingers and I hovered over the
keyboard and I wanted to apologize.
I want to apologize for being me.
I want to apologize for being 14 I
want to apologize for the whole fucking
thing.
I mean here,
but you know this is,
this is the first one.
This is the first one and I looked at it
and you're just fucking shut this thing
off.
Close the window.
Like what are we going to do?
I'm 43 years old.
I'm going to apologize for being a
Douche bag when I was 16 you're a con too
stupid.
What's it to basis?
You got the fucking fat.
Fuck you fucking western Massachusetts.
I went there once.
It drove an hour and a half.
You didn't even fuck me
because you were mad at me.
I just had that Joe.
It did.
I tell you what happened to me with this.
I write it down.
Somebody wrote something.
I had this x
chat me on Facebook and was like,
Hey,
I have something very
important to tell you,
like,
and I'm like,
what's it?
What is it?
And I'm like,
no,
I need to talk to you in person.
I can't do this over chat.
And this is from like 12 years
ago or something like that.
And so I'm like thinking,
all right,
it's one of three things that either I
have a child or I have aids or she found
Jesus.
It's like one of the three things,
right?
It's like I'm going to where Facebook.
And I'm like,
all right,
these kids look kind of retarded.
It might be mine.
I don't know to kind of look,
it looks a little Asian or whatever.
So she calls me up and she goes,
Hey,
I just want you to know something
that you remember that abortion,
you paid for it and like a year.
And she goes,
I just need money for heroin.
I started doing heroin after we
broke up and I really needed money.
So I made,
I said this whole thing that we're,
I was pregnant.
Oh,
I thought she said,
you told me.
She said she was pregnant with
another guy and it wasn't.
She said
I was pregnant with her
new heroin friend guy,
but they spent so much money on heroin.
They needed money and
I gave her like $500.
It wasn't like regular,
like
did you ever send the money back hunt?
No.
Hi.
Dot four seven 50 and suck my Dick Dude.
I said,
dude,
like interest.
Yeah,
you should at least get an
extra 250 bucks in a blow job.
It was crazy cause I saw him like heroin.
Hey,
beat off on her tits rot.
That's why I sold my comic books.
I forgot Coles and shooting loads.
Go Black.
I sold my comic books.
I forgot I sold my whole comic book
collection to pay for this abortion.
Okay,
well now she's a fuck ton.
She has ruined your iron man collection.
Yeah.
Okay.